ils sont des milliers dans les rues
depuis deux semaines dans le pays
des mobilisations contre le gouvernement
à l'isq des manifestants protestent
contre la réélection d'un président
qu'ils estiment illégitime
après plusieurs jours d'affrontements
les de répression violente les
contestataires espèrent un changement
pour leur pays
ici vous pouvez voir des femmes d'âge
différent nous sommes tous venus ici
avec le même objectif montrer que nous
défendons l'amour et la paix à travers
ces manifestations pacifiques
nous voulons dire aux forces de l'ordre
et aux autorités ce que nous voulons la
paix et l'amour en biélorussie
je ne peux pas regarder avec
indifférence ce qui se passe dans notre
pays
j'ai mal au coeur de voir les gens qui
ont été battus harcelée et menacée comme
ceux qui ont souffert ou ceux qui sont
morts je ne peux pas regarder cela avec
indifférence je veux vivre sous un
nouveau président je sais que tikhonov
sky a à gagner
nous avons voté pour elle c'est pour
cela que je suis ici des manifestations
également en soutien au pouvoir
de son côté le président loukachenko a
ordonné à son ministre de la défense de
prendre des mesures plus strictes pour
défendre l'intégrité territoriale du
pays
je charge le commandement opérationnel
en charge des frontières occidentales de
surveiller de la manière la plus stricte
les mouvements de toutes les unités
militaires des pays voisins membres de
l'otan je charge le comité national des
frontières de renforcer la sécurité sur
tout le périmètre des frontières de
l'état au crawl et chaque personne qui
vient ici à des fins illégales
pas un seul combattant pas un seul
provocateur pas une seule cartouche ne
doit pénétrer sur notre territoire
une situation politique tendue dont
l'issue reste incertaine lundi
le secrétaire d'état américain adjoint
stéphane beggen se rendra en lituanie
pays où la principale candidate de
l'opposition
svetlana terra nova scotia s'est réfugié
depuis maintenant plus de dix jours